[Music]
hi I'm Mike CML from FX guide.com for
wide it's been an amazing year for
visual effects and as the year comes to
a close and awards season starts we look
back at the top 10 films from a visual
effects point of view and at number 10
we have Maleficent is this incredible
look that Sleeping Beauty but Angelina
Jolie and some brilliant fully animated
character work this film was a huge hit
helping Disney to a global four billion
dollars this year but it was actually
the detailed face work from Digital
Domain that we really loved seeing at
number nine is Noah the visual effects
primarily by ILM were impressive
especially given the rather
non-traditional nature of the story but
for us it was the stunning stop frame
evolution of the world that was a
particularly arresting sequence this
volume of models and environments in
this one sequence was truly remarkable
and what had to be navigated was
incredible instead of just a rush of
images the VFX artists delivered an arc
that one could follow in a seamlessly
effortless sequence which of course must
mean anything but easy to make at number
8 is transformers age of extinction
yes ILM has done transformers before but
the addition of the Dinobots and
specifically the work of the effects
supervisor Scott Farrar and the new
hypno transform a sort of liquid blue
teeny particle effects the reassembly
was a great addition for the franchise
number 7 edge of tomorrow and we love a
good science fiction time-travel coda
story
and this one was both epic and engaging
the Saving Private Ryan meets Groundhog
Day the VFX supervisor Nick Davis made
the opening repeated battle never boring
and integrated the live-action exosuits
and the digital aliens extremely world
well Captain America takes us to number
6 with the Winter Soldier I limbs work
with the helicarrier's topped its own
work on Avengers something frankly we
didn't think was going to possible the
level of modeling and rigid body
simulation is exceptional
especially given the huge size of these
assets and the live-action environments
going into modeling teams probably don't
get the credit they deserve sometimes
but I'll em produced some of the year's
best models number five we have x-men
Days of Future past well there's a lot
of outstanding work in this film it
probably would have made our top 5 just
on the strength of the slow motion
prison breakout outstanding work from
Rising Sun pictures under the overall
supervision of Richard stammers together
they made a super slow-mo that was
engaging funny incredible and somehow
believable well if the slow-motion shots
propelled x-men then perhaps just the
comic-con trailer for Godzilla might
have helped that film make the list a
combined effort from MPC and Dini
Godzilla restored our faith in creature
monster films with some control
direction from Gareth Edwards we got to
film with much more than just
destruction porn and Godzilla they had
real character design but also
brilliantly motivated character
animation the MPC work over some monster
with a point of view thanks to some very
intelligent animation acting decisions
made by the guys at MPC all hand
keyframed by their artists at number
three interstellar such an accurate
scientific depiction of a black hole is
unprecedented the effects team had to
write not only an entirely new renderer
that could deal with the bending of rays
and a ray tracer but it also had to
model the way gravity actually affects
the very width of light beams and we
don't give away the ending but for those
of you that have seen this rather
pivotal plot point I'm sure you'd agree
with me that the ending is incredible
the end tesseract sequence with its
clever depiction of gravity waves in
time is brilliantly executed by double
negative in London headed by Paul
Franklin that sequence is simply the
best visualization work we've ever seen
but ultimately at number two is
guardians of the galaxy rarely have we
been so wrong about a film who would
have thought that a tree and a talking
raccoon could produce emotional action
sequences the sustained a major Marvel
film
at the vast army of 13 effects houses
produced strong characters immersive
environments all to a ripping 70s
soundtrack rocket acting with Groot has
to be one of the standout achievements
of this year perhaps only topped by the
film at number one dawn a Planet of the
Apes the emotional complexity that
sweater delivered in not just one but
multiple lead characters is incredible
the Shakespearean drama of betrayal and
conflict was stunning there's no doubt
that the rendering and character
pipelines atwitter and now the world's
most impressive this film shouldn't work
I mean just shouldn't it relies on
talking apes in extreme close-ups giving
nuanced performances and often wet
exterior conditions and yet Joel Atari
has built a pipeline and wetter obsessed
with getting things right and solving
problems properly and this all stands
arcing good stead for avatar two three
and four that are now in pre-production
not to mention Batman vs Superman dawn
of Justice
of course our list is based on visual
effects no doubt a little tainted by how
good we thought the overall story was
and how much we enjoyed the film but
then after all isn't that the role of
VFX to serve the story and he is not
over yet either we have some great films
still to come out such as The Hobbit the
Battle of the five armies coming out
right before Christmas so don't forget
to subscribe to see more on that and
other behind the scenes action I might
see more for why
[Music]